Public Sénat en partenariat avec laafp
les chchos Radio Classique
[Musique]
présent bonsoir à tous Thierry solaire
candidat avec l'étiquette LR candidat à
sa réélection à Boulogne billancour et
sans adversaire dans marche pour la
République et l'invité de cette émission
bonsoir Thierry solaire et merci d'être
avec nous pour les preuve de vérité donc
cette émission que vous propose chaque
semaine Public Sénat avec Radio
Classique les échos et l'Agence France
Presse vous répondrez ce soir à
Jean-Francis pcrè Débora Claude et
Oriane manchini avec trois grandes
questions qui vont vous être proposées
d'abord le début du du quinquena qui est
encensé après le baptême du feu réussi
sur le plan international par Emmanuel
Macron n'est pas n'est-il pas terni au
final par par l'affaire Richard Ferrand
2uxème question la sission du parti LR
qui fait ses deux an aujourd'hui même
est-elle inéluctable en raison notamment
de l'attitude compréhensive de certains
don vous envers le chef de l'État enfin
3è question les primaires dont vous avez
été un artisan engagé sont-elles selon
vous définitivement mortes et enterrées
après le fiasco que l'on connaî à droite
comme à gauche d'ailleurs mais d'abord
donc les
[Musique]
affaires et avec moi donc Jean-Francis
PC pour aborder ce chapitre qui s'impose
dans l' ité et qui peut même gommer la
campagne actuelle des législatifes peser
en tous les cas sur la Législative comme
ce climat des affaires a peser sur la
présidentiel Thierry solire les soupçons
d'affaires donc avec Richard Ferrand
Marielle de Sarnez et d'autres députés
européens le ministre de la cohésion des
territoires réfute ce soir toutes les
accusations qui sont portées contre lui
sur son mélange des gens ses liens
d'intérêt il rejette les soupçons donc
détaillé notamment par le journal Le
Monde alors que le Canard Enchaîné
enfonce le clou sur l'opération
immobilière à Brest avec le compromis de
vente qui avait été signé par Richard
Ferrand lui-même peut-il tenir selon
vous alors que les appels à la démission
se multipit à droite comme à gauche moi
je pense trois choses la première c'est
que toutes ces histoires à chaque fois
créent un soupçon dans l'opinion et que
en démocratie le soupçon c'est un
véritable poison et c'est très mauvais
collectivement dans la confiance qu'on
les Français dans la vie politique la
deuxième chose que je pense c'est qu'il
y a une jurisprudence qui date d'édoard
baladure qui a un membre du gouvernement
qui est mis en examen doit quitter le
gouvernement il est présumé innocent en
droit toujours mais il doit quitter le
gouvernement je pense que c'est c'est
bien que ça soit ainsi parce qu'on est
pas en capacité quand on est ministre et
qu'on est misise en examen d'assumer la
charge ministérielle que le Président de
la République et le Premier ministre
vous confi troisième chose je vois que
le ce gouvernement le président de la
République le Premier ministre prépare
nous ditons une loi de de modernisation
de moralisation de la vie politique bah
écoutez j'attendrai de savoir ce qu'il y
a dedans on le sait déjà hein quand même
les grandes mesures les grandes mesures
ont été présentées par par François
Baayou lui-même d'ailleurs écoutez moi
j'ai pas encore vu pardonnez-moi al
c'est peut-être moi qui a pas été très
vigilant mais je n'ai pas encore vu que
le Conseil des ministres ait eu
présentation de ce projet de loi il y a
des articles de presse qui nous parlent
de différents sujets moi j'attendrais de
voir ce qu'il y a dedans pour pas que ça
soit en fond un écran de fumée une loi
nouvelle de plus qui n'apporte rien et
donc à partir de là et là je vous
interrogz sur le cas spécifique de
Richard sur le cas spécifique de Richard
pas il est pas mis en examen la la
justice n'a pas été saisie mais est-ce
que vous comprenez quand même que le
premier ministre Matignon selon ce qui a
été rapporté cet après-midi conserve sa
confiance à ce ministre qui est dans la
tourmente aujourd'hui mais en alors que
alors qu'en vérité vous savez bien que
la tension monte en coulisse B écoutez
j'en sais rien moi la tension monte en
coulisse en tout cas ce que je constate
c'est que la justice pour l'instant
monsieur ferrant il y a pas
d'information judiciaire ni même
d'enquête préliminaire d'après ce que
j'ai lu euh qu'on est dans un état de
droit il faut laisser les magistrats
faire leur travail et que donc s'il
devait être mis en examen dans cette
affaire parce qu'il y aurait eu un délit
j'imagine que le premier ministre et le
président de la République en TI les
conséquences qu'il quitterait le
gouvernement vous comprenez et vous
défendez même le statut quo actuel c'est
Richard ferant toujours P c'est ça je
pense que c'est ça qu' un membre du
gouvernement qui est mise en examen
quitte alors qu'il a la présomption
d'innocence on en a vu des gens mis en
examen qui ont quitté le gouvernement et
qui ont été relaxés par les tribunaux
mais je pense qu'il est sain et je pense
que ce gouvernement ne changera pas de
de règles d'accord donc on vous pas de
procédure de justice donc il y a pas
d'affaire même si sur le plan moral
alors voilà c'est donc la différence
entre le droit et la morale et donc la
politique on nous donc une loi de
moralisation est-ce que il y a des
pratiques dans la vie politique qui si
elles sont légales ne sont plus
acceptées par les Français oui je le
pense probablement et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut une loi probablement pour
faire changer la loi pour que ces
pratiques qui sont légales mais qui ne
sont plus acceptés par les Français
n'est plus court je serais très attentif
à ce que ce gouvernement présentera pour
pas qu'il y ait un rideau de fumé
d'accord on va reparler alors il y a
d'autres accusations vous l'avez vu
aujourd'hui qui viennent àourdir ce
climac que j'aiévoqué elles av du du
Front National et elle vise trè 13
députés européens de toute tendance
Mariel de sarnz affirme qui ministre
elle affirme avoir respecté le règlement
du Parlement européen dans l'emploi de
son assistante mais le FN qui était le
premier mis en cause on le sait dans
cette affaire dénonce un deloit de
mesure alors qu'est-ce que vous dites
est-ce que c'est de bonne guerre ou
est-ce que c'est de la diffamation de la
part de l'extrême droite moi vous saz
j'étaé le porte-parole de François
Fillon jusqu'à ma démission le jour où
il a annoncé qu'il continuerait sa
campagne malgré sa mise en examen parce
qu'il avait dit lui-même que mise en
examen il arrêterait sa campagne moi
j'ai arrêté d'être pole à ce moment-là
je n'ai pas pendant toute la période où
j'aiété le porte-parole de François
Fillon mise en cause l'autorité
judiciaire et son indépendance moi je
suis député je suis candidat mais je
suis aujourd'hui député et le jour où
vous avez des députés qui commencent à
vous dire ce que la justice doit faire
la justice doit pas faire en mettant en
cause des procureurs ou des juges c'est
le début de la dictature donc moi j'en
reste à ce que la justice fasse son
travail les procureurs s'ils le
souhaitent ouvrent des enquête
préliminaire et il y a une jurisprudence
politique qui me paraît importante de
rappeler je pense que il sera nécessaire
que le premier ministre et le président
de la République la confirme parce que
c'est une règle qui est ancienne mais
qui n'est pas gravée dans la loi qui est
une règle de pratique qu'un ministre
mise en examin doit démissionner alors
après pour Marielle de sarnais dans la
dans la la ration que vous venez me
faire écoutez je n'ai aucun élément
d'information sur des accusations porté
par le Front national à l'endroit de
Madame de sarnaz et de ses
collaborateurs qui serais-je pour vous
donner mon avis et avoir des
informations en tout cas ce que je sais
c'est que tout ça irrite profondément
l'épiderme des Français et ront le lien
de confiance et donc il est important
s'il y a une nouvelle loi qui permet
d'améliorer les choses qu'elle soit
concrète et qu'elle permett que des
pratiques légal mais qui ne sont plus
accepté n''est plus lieu demain parce
qu'elle deviendrait illégale
Jean-Francis PC est-ce que vous n'avez
pas le sentiment quand même que ces
affaires ou ces affaires présumés en
tout état de cause viennent ternir jeter
une ombre sur les débuts d'un kquina qui
sont plutôt une réussite de Emmanuel
Macron ah ben c'est pas une bonne
affaire ça bien sûr dès que vous avez
pour qui que ce soit des mises en cause
c'est toujours désagréable et ce n'est
pas une bonne affaire je me doute bien
mais c'est pas moi qui suis chargé de ce
gouvernement que le premier ministre que
les intéressés sont satisfaits de cette
situation mais encore une fois moi je
suis un responsable politique je
n'essaie pas de jouer des amalgames de
jouer des peurs d'utiliser des mots que
je ne pense pas je suis respectuux
l'institution judiciaire j'attends par
contre du gouvernement qu'il rappelle ce
que je souhaite euh cette règle qui est
maintenant qui existe depuis plus de 20
ans qui est la mise en examen qui
gouvernement vous avez le sentiment
qu'il existe toujours au fond un lien
avec l'ancien monde de politique on
n'est pas on n pas basculé totalement
dans de nouvelles pratiques ben on le
verra encore une fois si la loi qu'on
nous annonce être la première loi s'il y
a une majorité pour le président de la
République qui sera proposé devant le
Parlement et dès le Conseil des
ministres si j'ai bien compris de la
semaine prochaine si cette loi vient
changer en droit ces pratiques là est-ce
que c'est ça qui est important oui alors
justement sur un un point de calendrier
est-ce que cette cette loi ou ces
projets de loi parce qu'il semble que
que en fait il y aurait trois textes
différents est-ce qu'ils doivent
impérativement être présenté au Conseil
et au français avant le premier tour des
élections législatives ou est-ce que
vous accepteriez qu'il le soit entre les
deux tours voir peut-être après le de
tour il semble qu'il a des je comprends
très bien votre question Monsieur P je
vais vous répondre aussi directement moi
je ne suis pas à donner des conseils au
président de la République et au Premier
ministre je suis député et je suis
candidats les républicains à Boulogne
billoncour à ma réélection moi je je
prendrai en tant que parlementaire je
verrai bien la majorité qu'il y ait
installé à l'Assemblée nationale et je
verrai bien de cette majorité le
gouvernement les textes qui nous
proposera le texte qui nous est annoncé
par le gouvernement et d'dard Philippe
qui vient d'être constitué est un texte
qui permettrait à les entendre mais je
ne l'ai pas lu parce qu'il n'est
toujours pas
disponible des
améliorations et je vous le dis je vous
le dis très clairement sur ce texte
comme sur tous les textes et je le dis à
mes électeurs dans la plus grande clarté
je voterai toutes les mesures qui vont
dans le bon sens pour le pays si il y a
lesqu par exemple ben par exemple si les
républicains ne devaient ne pas avoir la
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale je ne
m'opposerai pas aux ordonnances sur la
révision du Code du travail parce que je
pense que ça va dans le bon sens d'cord
mais sur la loi de moralisation et alors
il y a un certain nombre de points qui
ont été mis sur la table et que l'on
connaît comme l'interdiction pour un
député pour
même un parlementaire en général
d'employer des membres de sa famille
est-ce que vous êtes pour ou contre il y
a l'idée aussi de limiter le cumul des
mandats dans le temps est-ce que vous
êtes pour ou contre ces deux points et
limiter aussi les activité de conseil de
conseil trois questions donc euh la
première donc c'est sur la limitation
dans le temps la limitation dans le
temps je vous le dis très sincèrement je
pense que ce n'est pas une bonne idée je
ne suis pas sûr que ça soit
constitutionnel oh je vois bien
l'immense problème qu'on a surtout dans
ma famille politique qui est en train de
se régler d'ailleurs de décalage
générationnel je suis le seul
parlementaire des hautes scènes de
droite et du centre à ne pas avoir plus
de 68 ans donc vous prêchez un convaincu
pour autant je pense que ce n'est pas
très constitutionnel et j'ai souvenir vu
qu'on est sur publ Sénat le jour où
Robert bananter et Jean-Pierre Fourcat
donc quitit le Sénat je n'ai pas été
persuadé que ça a été une avancée
démocratique formidable ces deux
personnalités à porté formidablement à
la vie démocratique la deuxième question
elle est sur euh sur les emplo FAM
lesemp fam les emplois famiaux et puis
les activités de conseil vous aviez été
d'ailleurs on le rappelle vous même mis
en cause par le carard enchaîné alors
est-ce que vous accepteriez de voter ces
mesures sur les activités de conseil moi
je n'ai pas d'activités de conseil vous
dites que la réflexion globale a évolué
sur ces sujets la votre aussi alors moi
elle a évolué depuis longtemps il y a
des activités de conseil au Parlement
qui existent moi j'ai c'est toute
activité de conseil du jour où il y a
une nouvelle loi sur la transparence de
la vie politique et je suis très
favorable à leur interdiction pour une
raison très simple quand on est avocat
et qu'on est parlementaire et ben on
peut avoir des activités dans son cas
cabinet d'avocat par exemple qui ne
serait qui créerait des conflits
d'intérêt et comme par nature l'activité
d'avocat permet une confidentialité ce
n'est pas formidable donc je suis
favorable à la suppression des activités
de consultant ça c'est la première chose
et deux sur les emplois familiaux ou je
pense qu'il faut c'est c'est c'est
pratique par contre je ne veux pas être
hypocrite il ne faut pas simplement
faire cela le vrai problème n'est pas de
savoir si c'est un cousin si c'est un
enfant ou si c'est un parent le vrai
problème c'est de savoir si c'est fictif
ou pas et moi ce qui me paraît très
essentiel l'z fait vous-même d'ailleurs
votre épouse avait été bien sûr mon
épouse a travaillé avec moi mais le vrai
sujet c'est de savoir si ou pas est-ce
que les G on les qualifications ma femme
faits de droit elle gagne de fois moins
en travaillant avec moi que en
travaillant dans son ancien travail donc
tout ça n'a pas de difficulté la vraie
difficulté c'est quand c'est effictif qu
parce que là vous créez un soupçon
formidable et donc la vraie mesure c'est
bien sûr parce que le symbole est
important de cesser les emplois avec les
proches mais surtout d'assurer un
contrôle comme dans n'importe quelle
structure publique ou privée en France
que ça soit chez Radio Classique ou à
Public Sénat quand on est salariés du
structure on y h alors le début du
quinquena c'est aussi on l'a dit
Jean-Francis le baptême du feu
d'Emmanuel Macron sur la scène
internationale le bisut a réussi son
entrée hein si l'on en suit la presse
Sion suit la presse française et
internationale face à ses homologues
Trump et tous les autres et hier place à
Vladimir Poutine à à Versailles et face
à lui une vérité qui dérange le kémelin
on écoute le chef de l'État j'ai toujour
eu une relation exemplaire avec les
journalistes étrangers encore faut-il
qu'ils soit
journaliste et
les responsables politiques ont des
responsabilités de prendre des décisions
de dire les choses quand des organses de
presse répandent des contrevérités
infamantes ce ne sont plus des
journalistes ce sont des organes
d'influence ruchatoué et sputnck ont été
des organes d'influence durant cette
campagne qui ont à plusieurs reprises
produit des contevérités sur ma personne
et ma campagne est-ce que vous avez eu
hier en regardant le président Macron un
sentiment au fond un sentiment de fierté
je bien sûr euh moi je vais vous dire
dans la plus grande clarté cette
campagne présidentielle a été absolument
chaotique je n'ai pas voté pour Emmanuel
Macron j'ai voté pour François fillot en
premier tour j'ai appelé à voter pour
Emmanuel Macron à
20h1 quand il a été candidat face à
Marine Le Pen au soir du premier tour et
je je donc étais heureux qu'il soit élu
et que le Front national était écarté du
pouvoir depuis il est président de la
République et quoi qu'il arrive aux
élections législatives il sera le
président Macron pendant les 5
prochaines années le visage de la France
à l'international et c'est lui qui
présidera notre pays et je préfère à mon
mon pays à toute autre considération et
donc je me réjouis à chaque fois qu'une
décision va dans le bon sens et à chaque
fois que les choses se passent bien sur
la visite de Vladimir Poutine à Paris je
m'en réjouis parce que j'avais mal vécu
je pense que ce n'était pas l'intérêt de
la France enans polémique partisane avec
le président Hollande à l'époque le fait
que la France rompe en vrai toute
discussion diplomatique avec la Russie
rappelez-vous l'affaire des frégates que
nous avions refusé de livrer et donc le
le dialogue était rompu au fond la
diplomatie n'est pas de trouver les gens
bien ou pas bien la diplomatie c'est de
défendre ses propres intérêts
stratégiques et on ne défend pas ses
intérêts stratégiques en ne discutant
pas avec un le président d'une très
grande puissance comme celle de la
Russie j'ai trouvé le le démarrage
diplomatique du président Macron tout à
fait à la hauteur euh et et c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour la France et donc je
m'en réjouis est-ce que ce démarrage
diplomatique précisément est-ce que
c'est le retour de la France sur la
scène internationale ou est-ce que c'est
le retour est-ce que ça devrait être le
retour de l'Europe est-ce qu'il y a une
forme de
d'ambiguité notamment dans la relation
que Emmanuel Macron peut avoir avec
Angela Merkel et au fond on a deux
discours un discours qui est tenu par la
chancellère allemande un autre qui est
tenu hier et qui l'avait été face à
Trump le weekend dernier par le
président français est-ce que vous
trouvez que ce c'est aussi le retour de
l'Europe dans le concert des nations
alors d'abord le fait que la France est
un rôle important notamment dans la
crise en Syrie qu'on Renous les
dialogues avec la Russie que la France
existe à l'international plus qu'elle
l'a existé dans les précédentes années
je m'en réjouis deuxièmement le couple
franco-allemand s'est distendu dans le
précédent quinena en tout cas c'est une
préciation que je porte et je me suis
rendu à plusieurs fois pendant ce
quinena en Allemagne pour rencontrer mes
collègues du Bundestag et j'ai bien
senti le regard qu'il portait au-delà de
la droite et de la gauche
sur la situation de notre pays sur
l'absence de réformes structurell sur la
noncacité de tenir des engagements et
aujourd'hui nos nos partenaires
allemands vivent de toute évidence
l'élection du président Macron comme
l'opportunité maintenant c'est à vous
aussi vous êtes comme les Allemands mais
comme tous les Français les Français
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent ils veulent que
le pays se redresse par exemple Angela
Merkel a été beaucoup plus dur avec
Donald Trump que ne l'a été Emmanuel
Macron est-ce qu'il y a pas deux
discours au sein de l'Europe au sein de
ce couple franco-allemand mais la ligne
le fait de renforcer le lien et le
couple franco-allemand n'est pas pour
autant le gommage des différences et du
fait que l'expression des uns et des
autres n'est pas tout à fait la même sur
de nombreux sujets en matière de défense
par exemple Parn l'histoire de nos deux
pays n'est pas la même la France a une
puissance militaire importante ce qui
n'est pas le cas de l'Allemagne pour des
raisons historiques que tout le monde
connaît donc par nature nous avons des
liens différents mais encore une fois
l'important c'est quoi c'est que
l'Europe elle avance et qu'elle apporte
des résultats concrets aux
problématiques que vivent les Européens
euh sur un plan économique sur un plan
migratoire qu'elle soit plus efficace
qu'elle ne soit pas que dans les
incantations elle a trop souvent
l'Europe donner le visage de n'essayer
de régler les difficultés que au devant
devant la difficulté on se rappelle de
la crise financière avec la Grèce on se
rappè de la crise des migrants o on
voyait des réunions toute la nuit qui
tournent un peu en rond moi ce que
j'attends euh de mon pays euh c'est
qu'il joue son rôle au niveau
international et que le couple
franco-allemand puisse se renforcerord
on voit on voit le chef de l'État
imposer un ton nouveau hein et
revendiquer d'ailleurs une présidence
jupitérienne Thierry solire même
certains craignent un pouvoir personnel
qui serait au détriment du Premier
ministre votre ami Édouard Philippe ça
vous inquiète éventuellement que à
matigon on n plus qu'un simple
collaborateur non mais tout ça je r pas
du tout dans ces discussions moi je suis
député la seule chose qui m'importe je
vais vous dire les choses très
clairement si les habitants de boulog me
font confiance ils auront un député de
droite et du centre c'est les valeurs
qui sont les mienes je n pas changé
depuis l'élection présid et sur la
présidence française et sur l'action du
gouvernement je voterai toutes les
réformes qui vont dans le bon sens d'où
qu'elles viennent parce que l'état de
notre pays nous impose me semble-t-il
qu'on ait des résultats je ne
m'intéresse pas à 2022 on aura bien le
temps mi 2021 de s'intéresser à la
prochaine
présidentielle nous à notre pays des
conséquences de ce que vous dites quand
même sur votre parti à l' on en parle
dans un instant avec Débora Claude de la
FP qui nous rejoint merci beaucoup
Jean-Francis l'épreuve de vérité avec la
FP bonsoir Débora bonsoir bonsoir
Thierry bonsoir alors vous êtes
constructif Thierry solaire à vous
faites partie de ELR est-ce que vous
êtes Macron
compatible pas ce que ça veut dire je
suis un député de droite et du centre
j'ai vu que le président disait qu'il
était de gauche et de droite ben moi je
suis de droite et du centre euh est-ce
que je préfère mon mon pays à toute
autre considération la réponse est oui
le président Macron a été élu euh et il
donc légitime moi je souhaite la
réussite de mon pays qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire concrètement arrivriver à
l'Assemblée nationale si les habitants
de Boulogne me font confiance je
porterai toujours les valeurs qui sont
les miennes dans quel groupe je suis
républicains je n'ai pas brevet de
républicains à donner je suis
l'organisateur des primaires de ma
famille politique euh la seule chose qui
m'imorte encore une fois c'est qu'on ne
soit pas ce qu'on est trop souvent
gauche et droite depuis 40 ans dans
notre pays dans des postures politiques
moi j'en ai entendu euh des députés de
droite quand on était dans l'opposition
qui disait quand on est dans
l'opposition on s'oppose même si le
texte est bon et ben écoutez ça c'est
fini parce que je considère que la
situation de notre pays nous impose de
prendre nos responsabilités et donc à
l'inverse de beaucoup je le dis à mes
électeurs dès aujourd'hui sur les sujets
économiques sur ce qui renforcera la
sécurité des Français sur la fluidité du
marché du travail sur la baisse des
charges vous voteriez les ordonnances la
réforme qu'est-ce que vous pourriez
voter d'autres dans le programme
d'Emmanuel Macron éventuellement dans un
groupe d'appui à l'Assemblée nationale
toute mesure qui donnera plus de
sécurité plus de compétitivité
d'économique à notre pays euh et plus de
renforcement de l'État régalien euh en
voilà dans le cadre donc d'un groupe
d'appui comme le dit Débora donc c'est
la question que l'on vous pose est-ce
que selon vous au lendemain des
législatives la sission de votre parti
l'R est inélictable ou pas on a
constitué ils ont constitué j'ai adéré
des sa création à l'UMP à les
républicains aujourd'hui en 2002 suite à
la présence de Jean-Marie Le Pen au
second tour de la présidentielle c'était
une stratégie euh d'union de la droite
et du centre dans la même famille
politique pour nous permettre d'avoir
une majorité à l'Assemblée nationale on
sait ça ne m'a pas échappé à personne je
pense que la droite et le Centre ont été
éliminé dès le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle avec la
candidature de François Fillon donc bien
sûr qu'il y a une crise importante il
faait refonder un nouveau
parti non mais moi je suis pas dans une
logique de ce tout de suite de ce
scinder ce que je cherche c'est à
convaincre et à discuter avec mes
collègues en leur disant on est un parti
issu du gaulisme on est un parti
pro-européen on est un parti qui défend
des valeurs de liberté économique
d'autorité de l'État voulez que LR et
moi je ne veux pas soit dans d'autres
considérations sinon c'est pas on est
plus LR on est autre chose est-ce que
vous à titre disons personnel vous payez
pas votre votre ouverture d'esprit votre
côté constructif à la présidence à la
présidence du groupe de la région
Île-de-France puisque vous l'vez quitté
cette présidence est-ce que c'est pas le
prix aussi à payer de cet engagement
comme ça plus droite plus gauche de bon
sens là comme vous l'avez répété moi
j'ai une caractéristique des borac
Claude je n'en nuse pas mais par contre
je la revendique je suis quelqu'un de
très libre je ne dois mon élection de
député de Boulain billoncour qu'X
habitant de Boulogne billancour j'avais
été candidat face à Claude guéand en
2012 qui avait été parachuté dans ma
ville et je dis ce que je pense aux
électeurs s'ils ne se reconnaissent pas
qui ne sont pas sur la même ligne que
moi probablement ne V ne voteront-il pas
pour moi et vous n'avez pas de candidat
en marche dans votre je pas non plus de
candidat socialiste ni candidat de la
France vous avez été débarqué de votre
présidence de groupe au conseil général
ça quoi ça augure de violence à venir
avec Valérie PC on partage ça arrive
rarement quand même de c'est tous les
dans les autres groupes qu'il y a des
élections à la présidence des groupes
moi ça fait un an et demi que j'y suis
et en discutant avec Valérie pcrè on a
tous les deux une volonté très forte ne
pas importer les débats qui peut y avoir
de sens commun au Parti démocrate avec
d'autres tendances de la droite au sein
du fonctionnement de la région
Île-de-France pourquoi parce que Valérie
pcrè avec son équipe elle redresse la
région depuis maintenant 18 mois et il
ne faut pas que ça change la majorité de
régionale de Valérie pcrè c'est l'UDI
c'est le modem les modem est dans la
majorité présidentielle c'est les
républicains entre le parti
chrétiendémocrate et moi il y a sûrement
des plus que des nuances tout ça c'est
très bien on redresse la région donc je
ne veux pas qu'on importe et moi j'ai
souhaité me consacrer pleinement à ma
campagne législative et à
momentpp je vous rappelle et je vous
rappelle que je suis l'un des quatre
députés de droite qui a voté la loi qui
restreint cumule des mandats donc je
suis aussi cohérent avec quel est votre
premier argument de campagne quand vous
êtes le terrain dans votre sur le
terrain dans votre ville dans les
marchés de boulog billancour quoi vous
êtes là pour défendre le programme l
vous êtes là pour dire que vous êtes
prêt à soutenir le chef de l'État quel
est votre premier argument auprès de vos
électeurs c'est très simple les
habitants ils me connaissent bien
connaissent les valeurs mais c'est très
très simple vous allez voir et je
l'écris noir sur blanc dans ma
profession de foi je leur explique que
si elle est un majoritaire à l'Assemblée
nationale bien sûr nous nous
gouvernerons le pays le président de la
République le présidera sondage ne nous
donne pas à priori ces indications là
Franois Barouin ne parle plus de
cohabitation C d'ailleurs une évolution
don je me réj je me réjouis de ça
d'ailleurs François baron d'ailleurs
fait un travail difficile et et et et
très bien je trouve dans cette campagne
législative et je leur explique que de
droite je suis et que j'ai toujours été
mais que je veux que mon pays avance et
que donc si nous devions ne pas être
majoritaire à l'Assemblée nationale
parce qu'ils ont très bien compris les
français ce qui s'est passé
l'élimination de François Fillon et
l'évolution aujourd'hui politique je ne
serai pas un député destructeur dans
l'opposition bête et M ça vous attire
pas d'insulte on vous traite pas de
traître mais en rien au contraire les
Français vous savez ils préfèrent ils
préfèrent rien d'autre que le
redressement de leur pays accusations
vous entre les tenneurs entre eux alors
vous avez 9 millions de pauvres 6
millions de chômeurs du terrorisme et de
l'insécurité est-ce que vous croyez
qu'on peut attendre 5 ans à votter
compte des lois qui vont dans le bon
sens tout ça parce que la majorité dans
laquelle que les Français auront choisi
n'est pas le groupe dans laquel vous
appartenez citer françois Barouin on va
l'écouter justement il défend l'idée que
à bas à droite aussi il y a il y a des
talents je me bat pas pour l'opposition
je me bat pour avoir une majorité pour
la France avec nos candidats ils sont à
60 % renouv renouvelés ils incarnent une
génération qui se lève qui demande un
espoir et le monopole du renouvellement
n'est pas du côté d'en marche je pense
que la majorité est possible est-ce
qu'elle est absolue est-ce qu'elle est
relative dans quelle proportion sous
quelle forme mais le choix que nous
proposons le projet qui a été modifié
que nous portons est un projet
susceptible de rassembler les Français
et quand je dis constructif c'est que
nous respectons les institutions
Emmanuel Macron est élu il est là pour 5
ans sa tâche est immense et nous
souhaitons le succès de la France et que
je n'utilise pas non plus le terme
cohabitation parce que ça ramène à passé
où les présidents sortants ont été
battus où les présidents en place ont
été battus c'était le cas de miteran où
ça a été le cas de Chirac au moment des
cohabitations c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait nouveau et donc c'est
quelque chose qui doit se vivre dans
l'apaisement et pas la confrontation
mais dans la mise en lumière des
divergences profondes qui existent entre
en marche les républicains udi voà bon
c'est la France apaisée la
France j'ai été à l'initiative avec
Gérald armanin avec d'autres app un
appel qui é signé par beaucoup de
grand-mèr de président de département de
président de Région de parlementaire qui
visait justement à ne pas être dans
cette posture de facilité de caricature
perpétuelle de dire on est de droite on
s'opposera donc si on est minoritaire à
tout ce que fait vous dit c'est la l
officiain je suis ravi de voir je suis
ravi de voir que François par est un
homme d'une grande qualité aujourd'hui
dire cela parce que les Français c'est
ce qu'ils attendent et un électeur de
droite à boulette Bill en cour qu'est-ce
qu'il me dit il me dit c'est exactement
moi ce que je lui dis d'ailleurs
c'est-à-dire on a eu une année
électorale terrible on a maintenant ce
jeune président et manuel Macron qui
préside notre pays pour 5 ans on a un
gouvernement c'est pas rien avec un
Premier ministre qui est issu de noran
et Édouard Philippe c'est globalement ce
qu'on avait de mie en magasin
disons-nous les choses la seule chose
qu'ils veulent si les républicains ne
sont pas majoritaires c'est que ça
avance c'est que ça marche donc moi je
suis pas en marche mais je veux que ça
marche et est-ce que vous êtes également
pour la position qu'il a prise hier soir
sur le désistement républicain en cas de
menace qui n'est pas le cas dans votre
circonscription mais de menace de
victoire du Front national parce qu' il
y a une petite évolution il y avait eu
quand même des atermoim après après le
second tour
là il y a une petite évolution moi
j'avais mal vécu je l'avais dit
d'ailleurs publiquement que mon parti
politique semble un peu tortillé à
prononcer le nom d'Emmanuel Macron au
lendemain du premier tour quand on a le
front national qui est au porte du
pouvoir au second tour d'une
présidentielle et qu'on est soit même
pas qualifié nous la droite française on
appelle clairement à voter pour Emmanuel
Macron je l'ai fait à 2h1 deuxièmement
Gill Boyer qui est le candidat au
législative à chaveville Medon là dans
mon département voisin de
circonscription hier matin a proposé
qu'il y ait un débat dans ma famille
politique autour justement de cette
histoire de désistement en C
triangulaire pour ne pas favoriser si on
a aucune chance de l'emporter l'élection
d'un député frontiste un débat qui aura
lieu après le premier tour oui enfin qui
aura lieu tout de suite au lendemain du
second tour et j'étais très heureux de
voir que françois Barouin éta exactement
sur la même ligne que je partage à 100%
mais alors je comprends pas une chose
parce que vous avez dit à l'instant que
Édouard Philippe c'est ce que vous avez
de mieux en magasin vous venez de le
dire mais c'est pas françois Barouin qui
postule également à Matignon c'est pas
lui votre ne postule pas matinon le
Premier ministre quand même il est c'est
un peu ce qui a été indiqué ce serait
pas lui plutôt il serait pas bien
on ne postule pas à matigon François
baron a toutes les qualités pour être un
bon premier ministre mais on ne postule
pas à matigon le Premier ministre est
nommé par le Président de la République
issu d'une majorité françois Barouin a
fait un grand travail pour essayer de
porter nos 577 candidats mais vous voyez
bien que c'est difficile et comment ça
ne le serait pas après l'élimination d
le premier tour de la présidentielle de
notre famille politique encore une fois
onppelle du déftisme pas du tout ça
s'appelle du réalisme et je je soutiens
moi tous mes collègues les républicains
qui sont candidats et c'est pas facile
bien sûr après ce qui s'est passé mais
encore une fois moi je préféis toujours
mon pays à mon parti et je dis à ma
famille politique auquel j'adhère depuis
le premier jour àqu j'ai consacré
beaucoup d'énergie pour leur faire une
primaire de bien
organisé l'a dit que il faut vraiment
qu'on sorte de ces postures politique
parce que le pays doit se redresser mais
qui est le leader politique de dans
votre famille est-ce que c'est françois
Barouin est-ce que c'est Laurent vquier
qui un petit peu conspuer les gens qui
allaient à la soupe ces dernières
semaines comment ai l'Assemblée
nationale l'avenir du parti nous avons
collégialement demandé à françois
Barouin qui a bien voulu le faire il est
sénateur et président de la MF d'être le
chef de file de cette campagne des
élections législatives et la vie des
républicains continuera après et il y
aura des débats il y aura des élections
internes tout ça est très intéressant
aujourd'hui qui est le meilleur en
magasin pour direr et vous vous sentez
plus proche d'Emmanuel Macron que de le
renvoquer par exemple écoutez je pas
répondreure pas les choses comme ça ça
dépend sur quel sujet ça dépendement
écoutez moi je suis européen
profondément je considère que l'avenir
de la France ça passe par l'Europe il
faut renforcer l'acement libéral sur un
plan économique je suis favorable à une
autorité de l'État importante et je
déteste les phrases élevées et les
résultats faibles je préfère des phrases
mesurées et des résultats forts voilà ma
caractéristique personnelle dans cette
affaire mais encore une fois les
histoires de partis intéressent
particulièrement les Françaises j'en
suis certain ils intéressent encore plus
c'est l'avenir du pays et en votant moi
je le dis clairement à mes électeurs on
doit construire on doit pas être dans
ses postures de position qui n'ont que
trop duré Xavier Bertrand dans une
interview ce matin à La Voix du Nord
estime qu'Emmanuel Macron n'est pas du
tout dans une logique d'union nationale
il le dit comme ça mais il fait
simplement de l'ouverture un comme miter
en 88 ou Sarkozi en 2007 et il n'a pas
envie de s'ouvrir aux autres selon
Xavier Bertrand ça n'est pas votre avis
non je pense pas ça l'ouverture c'est ce
qui avait été fait notamment dans le
quinc Nicolas Sarkozi là c'est pas de
l'ouverture on a nommé et le président
de la République a nommé édard Philippe
c'est un pas vers l'Union nationale
c'est en tout cas nommé quelqu'un qui
n'est pas issu de son majorité à lui HM
comme président de la République donc il
cherche de toute évidence à rassembler
différentes personnalités différentes
forces politiques mais il s'adresse plus
au français je pense le président qu'
parti il essaie de de constituer une
majorité pour de de projet et moi au
Parlement encore une fois pardon de vous
le dire aussi clairement j'assume de
vous le dire ce n'est pas des stratégies
à 23 bandes c'est très simple c'est
beaucoup plus simple que ça j'ai 45 ans
je viens de passer 5 ans à l'Assemblée
nationale je trouve que le pays va mal
la seule chose qui m'importe c'est que
le pays a le mieux dans quelques années
et puis après c'est pas une ouverture
cosmétique c'est vraiment une
révolution il le faut il il faut que nos
collègues parlementaires d'où qu'ils
viennent arrêent les postures et et soit
dans l'efficacité de voter les bonnes
réformes il est important que le pays
aille mieux dans 5 ans dites-vous c'est
effectivement essentiel Thierry solaire
parce que si le président de la
République réunit une union nationale si
c'est l'échec l'alternative ce seront
les extrêmes pe pas donc il y a un vrai
danger il y aura ne vous inquiétez pas
l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron n'enlève
pas la vie démocratique dans 5 ans il y
aura une prochaine présid ti et par
nature il y aura des offres politiques
qui sert sur la table et le président de
la République comme ses prédécesseurs
sera jugé à l' des résultats qui sont
les siens moi ce n'est pas un homme que
je veux soutenir c'est mon pays je
seraai heureux quel que soit le résultat
de la prochaine présidentielle qu'il ait
moins de chômeurs en France dans 5 ans
qu'il y en a aujourd'hui qu'il y ait
plus de sécurité et que la France est
mieux répondu à la menace terroriste qu'
a répondu depuis quelques années merci
beaucoup Débora dernière partie de
l'épreuve de vérité avecian monchini DEP
Public Sénat qui nous rejoint
maintenant
bonsoir Orian bonsoir Michel bonsoir
bonsoir ti solaire alors vous avez été
un l'artisan de de la primaire de la
droite et du centre les deux finalistes
de la présidentielle n'étaient pas issus
de primaire benoî amont et François
Fillon qui eux ont remporté leur
primaire ont été éliminé est-ce que pour
vous les primaires sont définitivement
mortes et enterré je le crois pas
d'abord je ne suis pas l'origine du fait
de faire des primaires à droite je suis
celui à qui on a
chargéorganiser c'est Nicolas Sarkozi
qui président du parti qui a proposé
à tout le monde de faire des primaires
et il m'a chargé de les faire de les
primaires ça règle pas tout les
primaires ne vous donnent jamais la
garantie d'être présent les primaires
elles ont trois intérêts la première
elle crée elle règle le problème du
leadership vous imaginez si on avait eu
Alain Jupé François Fillon et Nicola
Sarkozi tous trois candidats au premier
tour c'était même pas envisageable que
qu'on ne soit pas qu'on soit présent que
l'un des trois soit présent est-ce que c
Pasj un problème qui a eu besoin de
régler ce problème du leadership non je
crois pas non je crois pas je pense que
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs quand il y a
quelqu'un qui incarne un leadership très
fort le fait de faire des primaires ne
lui pose pas de problème rappelez-vous
Nicolas Sarkozi en 2007 il avait un très
fort leadership à droite vous croyez que
si on lui avait demandé de faire des
primaires ouvertes pour désigner le
candidat de la droite en 2007 il aurait
eu difficulté à se soumettre à cet
exercice il aurait bien sûr été candidat
les aurait gagné très nettement parce
que les Français voyaient en lui un
espoir très clair de redressement donc
encore une fois ne cherchons pas à
donner au primaire un outil un objectif
qu'ils n'ont pas les primaires règlent
le problème de leadership elles ont
aussi comme vertu de de mobiliser
beaucoup de Français 4 millions et demi
sur deux dimanches successifs et donc ça
me paraîtêtre un outil intéressant après
la troisième remarque c'est que la
gauche est sorti de ce quinquena dans un
état terrible parce que leur bilan a été
négatif et il a été tellement négatif
que le président sortant François
Hollande qui n'avait comme boussole que
de se représenter a fini par renoncer à
s'y présenter il était donc assez
évident que quel que soit l'issu de la
prim ire il y a peu de chance que le
Parti socialiste produise le prochain
Président de la République voilà alors
on va écouter ce que dit justement Anne
levad qui a présidé la Haute Autorité de
avec vous de la primaire avec beaucoup
de talent c'est vrai Anne Levade une
constitutionnaliste que l'on apprécie
d'ailleurs sur Public Sénat on la reçoit
souvent et justement elle donne un
pronostic qui ressemble au vôtre sur sur
la
suite alors je pense que le mode de
sélection des candidats par un parti il
est très étroitement conjoncturel le
choix qui avait été fait de sélectionner
par le biais d'une primaire cette année
était évidemment lié à la volonté
d'avoir un unique candidat pour la
droite et Le Cendre comme d'ailleurs un
unique candidat pour le Parti socialiste
alors que a priori il y avait plusieurs
candidats possibles et que donc ça
obérait assez lourdement l'issue finale
de l'élection présidentielle quen
sera-t-il pour laavenir ou dans 5 ans je
ne sais pas c'est vrai qu'un mode de
sélection qui va au-delà des seuls
adhérants part parti semble quand même
un un mode de sélection qui aujourd'hui
est plébiscité d'ailleurs le nombre
d'électeurs l'a démontré et j'en veux
pour preuve le fait que c'est un système
qui ne fonctionne pas que pour les
présidentiels je rappelle que par
exemple pour les municipales dans un
certain nombre de grandes communes la
droite comme la gauche on utiliser ce
système on on en a pas fini avec les
primaires je partage parfaitement ce que
vient de dire Anne levad très bien je
crois pas en plus que quand on donne un
pouvoir au français il ne le garde pas
et la capacité de choisir parmi dans
unee famille politique 3 4 5 ou si
postulants celui ou celle qui porte euh
c'est c'est formidable et enfin pardon
de le dire aussi franchement ce n'est
pas la primire qui a fait perdre
François Fillon c'est une défaite
personnelle ah bah c'est deux choses me
semble-t-il c'est son affaire il est
arrivé en il a gagné la primaire en
faisant de la probité de l'exemplarité
une caractéristique très forte il s'est
retrouvé lui-même empêtré dans une
affaire il a dit aux Français de sur une
chaîne de grande écoute que s'il devait
être mise en examen il ne sera pas
candidat il est revenu un mois après
pour dire qu'il était mise en examen il
allait continuer et enfin il s'est
resserré peut-être lié à cela d'ailleurs
il s'est resserré sur simplement une
partie de l'électoral de la droite euh
et et on n pas parlé suffisamment au
français vous dites que c'est c'est pas
la primaire qui a fait perdre François
Fillon mais est-ce que c'est pas la
primaire qui vous a empêché d'avoir un
recours à François Fillon quand quand le
Penelope gate a commencé puisque lui
s'est appuyé sur la légitimité de cette
primaire c'est vrai euh c'est un des des
conséquences c'est que quand vous êtes
porté par une légitimité parce que vous
avez gagné une primière devant 4 million
et demi de Français c'est une faiblesse
du système que vous avez mis en en tout
cas c'est un des effets induits d'un are
côté on était déjà en mars si vous
croyez que les on peut changer le
candidat investi dans un parti
facilement ah certains l'avaient
envisagé hein oui mais c'était le celui
le seul qui avait la réponse vous
peut-être oui moi je diffment je lui
avais dit d'ailleurs après je suis
respectueux moi je me suis effacé de sa
décision il avait le droit en droit de
le faire il était le candidat vainqueur
de la primaire il avait on lui avait
apporté les l'argent collecté à la
primaire aussi hein pour faire sa
campagne présidentielle il a souhaité la
continuer il en avait le droit juridique
est-ce que est-ce que vous avec le recul
vous avez des regrets sur cette période
est-ce que s'il fallait refaire quelque
chose aujourd'hui vous referiez quelque
chose différemment bah écoutez d'abord
j'essaie de pas avoir de remord c'est
déjà bien mais des regrets on en a
toujours en tout cas ce qui moi j'aiété
content de la manière dont ça a été
organisé parce que souvent nos partis
politiques ne donnent pas une image de
grande rigueur et là tout le monde a
joué le jeu il y a eu aucune
contestation et on a réussi à mobiliser
80000 français qu' organisaient ce
scrutin avec 4 million et demi de
votants c'est absolument considérable
c'est la plus grosse consultation
européenne qui n''est jamais eu lieu
privé organisé par une formation
politique euh après ben le regret c'est
l'issue mais je crois pas que ça soit
encore une fois la primaire qui soit à
la C et vous vous êtes beaucoup investi
hein dans cette primaire he vous n'avez
pas compté vos heures hein pour le coup
aujourd'hui quel sentiment vous en
gardez c'est plutôt de la fierté ou vous
vous dites quel gâie tout ça pour ça ah
ben plutôt qu' Gashi bien sûr parce que
les primaires avaient donné la avaient
permis de rassembler les conditions de
la victoire et au-delà de la victoire
pour la victoire du redressement du pays
et en fait tout ça c'est terminé par une
élimination dès le premier tour mais
encore une fois moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est c'est pas de regarder dans le
rétroviseur c'est de regarder devant moi
et la seule chose qui m'importe c'est
que le pays se redresse et que cette
année 2017 soit utile l'année 2018 soit
utile l'année 2019 soit utile et qu'on
prenne les mesures qui ont été pris par
schrer en Allemagne alors on l' bien
compris he on en a déjà parlé c'est bien
de le dire c'est l'essentiel sur un plan
un peu plus personnel hein Thierry
solaire vous êtes proche de de Bruno Le
Maire qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de
son entrée au gouvernement bah d'abord
je suis proche ou de Bruno d'édoard
Philippe énormément qui qui est vraiment
mon ami on a beaucoup travaillé en
ensemble d'ailleurs à la primaire dard
était le représentant de d'alin Jupé et
puis c'est très générationnel avec
Gérald darmana avec d'autres on a
énormément travaillé ensemble on a une
relation de grande confiance ils font
une analyse qui est de rentrer tout de
suite au gouvernement parce qu'on leur a
proposé d'y rentrer il n'était pas
candidat aux élections législatives et
il considèr qu'au fond de ce cafarnaom
qu'on vient de vivre depuis un an il est
maintenant temps vous les avez encouragé
j'ai pas besoin mais je dit que je
comprenais la démarche qui était la
l'URE et qu'en tout cas je n'ai aucun
doute qu' do Philippe Bruno Lem et et
Gérald armanin ils veulent faire quelque
chose d'utile pour le pays et puis
j'auris du mal à vous dire que c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle d'avoir un un ministre
de l'Économie et un ministre du Budget
comme Édouard Philippe comme Bono le mer
voilà etdard Philipp je vous l'ai dit
est vraiment un quelqu'un d'une immense
qualité morale intellectuelle quelqu'un
qui qui qui qui a un vrai sens de l'État
et qui n'est pas là uniquement enfin qui
n'est pas là du tout d'ailleurs pour la
gloriole ou je ne sais quoi qui est là
pour faire des choses et et ça c'est
bien après les Français vont choisir
leur parlementaires librement
tranquillement et encore une fois que
tout ça soit utile justement Bruno
leemire qui est donc devenu ministre de
l'Économie pendant la primaire dans son
programme il défendait notamment une
baisse de la CSG aujourd'hui il va
devoir mener en œuvre le programme
d'Emmanuel Macron qui lui prévoit une
augmentation de 1,7 %. est-ce que c'est
crédible pour le nouveau ministre de
l'économie de défendre ça alors qu'il a
dit le contraire pendant des mois bon
d'abord il y a trop d'impô en France là
il y aura 22 milliards supplémentaires
en tous les cas même s'il y a un
allègement bien sûr sur les actifs voilà
mais il y a trop trop d'impô en France
il y a trop de charge sur le monde du
travail il y a le choix de la TVA il y a
le choix de la CSG au casun est exemple
de de reproches de difficultés la chose
qu'il faut c'est que l'économie reparte
c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera à baisser
la fiscalité il faut être cohérent à
partir du moment où il s'engage dans
cette affaire et il faut qu'il y ait une
solidarité gouvernementale et c'est le
président de la République qui a été élu
soit on se détourne de son pays et on
s'occupe d'autres choses soit on fait de
la politiqueér c'est cohérent voilà
est-ce que c'est cohérent de faire le
contraire qu'onêché pendant des mois je
vous dire vous avez tro positions
possible vous voterez vous vous voterez
ce texte par exemple sur la hausse de la
CSG qui va frapper les retraités et puis
les indépendants est-ce que vous voterez
ce texte par principe c'est un texte
ou une cohérence globale fiscale moi je
je ne voterai pas des hausses d'impôts
qui ne permettent pas de faire démarrer
l'économie ce n'est pasctif de la ha
vous estimez que c'est courageux alors
je je pense trois choses enfin je pense
une chose profondément par rapport à
votre question de fond qui est que un
député de droite àprès qu'inquena dans
la situation qui est celle du pays il a
trois solutions soit il retourne à ses
activités antérieures et
professionnelles soit il passe 5 ans à
faire de l'obstruction si on n'est pas
majoritaire soit il essaie de faire
avancer le pays et je oui on a compris
que vous vouliz faire avancer le pays
sur des mesures qui qui correspondent à
à vos valeurs à vos convictions là
visiblement ce n'est pas le cas de Bruno
Lemer est-ce que ce n'est pas un peu
d'opportunisme de sa part mais vous avez
vous vous partez du principe que tout
est figé qu'il n'y aura pas de
discussion que tout est écrit que vous
savez exactement ce qui se passera et
tout moi je vous dis
on part du principe qu'Emmanuel Macron
est parti pour tenir ses promesses en
tout cas visiblement il n PASF cgug
augmenter la CG mais il y aura pas de
TVA sociale par exemple qui était sur le
programme de franoph mais vous sa à
l'occasion de la primaire il y avait je
sais plus quel était celui des candidats
principaux qui proposaient
l'augmentation de la CSG je crois qu'il
y en avait c'était des mesure qui était
tout à fait envisagé moi je pense que
c'est un défaut majeur c'est notamment
ça pèse sur le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités notamment des plus modestes
parce que le niveau auquel ils sont
touchés et quand même un niveau de
pension qui est quand même très bas donc
voilà donc çaa partie des choses qui
aura exactement quia amandé et moi
comprenez-moi bien je ne suis pas dans
une logique de changer de parti je ne
suis pas en marche je mon pays marche et
je ne suis pas là pour donner des
blancins au nouveau président de la
République et son gouvernement je vous
dis juste qu'il va falloir qu'à un
moment donné et c'est pas la peine de
faire des grandes tambouilles politiques
pour ça que chaque parlementaire de
notre pays avance en conviction pour que
le pays redécolle alors vous n'êtes pas
dans la logique de changer de parti mais
le parti leslr s'est droitisé pendant la
primaire là on parle de le renvoquer
pour prendre sa tête qui est sur une
ligne de droite du vous vous êtes plutôt
sur une ligne de droite modérée pourquoi
vous restez encore au sein deslr est-ce
que vous vous sentz encore à l'aise dans
ce parti mais d'abord j'aime pas le mot
modéré ça fait mou et je crois pas être
mou du tout je préfère avoir des
positions qui sont précises et avoir des
actes forts et je me méfie toujours de
ceux qui vous viennent avec des grandes
phrases et des grandes mesures et qui
quand ils sont au pouvoir en général
n'en font pas 10 % euh donc ça c'est la
première chose deuxièmement il y a des
différences dans une famille politique
n'est pas grave en soi et il y a un
débat par contre il y a un ADN et l'ADN
de la droite et du centre droit français
celle de l'UMP des républicains c'est
d'être pro européen c'est d'être
réformateur c'est d'être libéral sur un
plan économique et celle de restaurer
l'autorité de l'État par contre si c'est
pour faire des amalgames et des postures
ça m'intéresse pas et donc voilà si on
est majoritaire sur cette ligne je
seraai heureux je serai heureux pour ma
famille politique mais vous me parlez
énormément des partis politique vous
nous enfermez beaucoup dans des cases et
je vais vous dire je me sens plus député
de boulem billoncour que député LR
alors-moi quand même on a compris que
vous parliez régulièrement peut-être
depuis leur nomination à édard Philippe
à Bruno le à Gérald armanin c'est le cas
j'imagine vous échangez et vous échangez
aussi avec Alain Jupé aussi j'imagine
car il vous a apporté aujourd'hui son
soutien par un tweet en saluant votre
démarche constructive alors en fait vous
nous dites que il est aussi en manœuvre
en coulisse là l'ancien Premier ministre
pas problème de manœuvre le Alain Jupé
est un homme d'État qui a de grandes
qualités il n'a pas d'autre ambition
d'être maire de Bordeaux je crois il l'a
dit dans la plus grande clarté il veut
pour son pays le meilleur et tout ce qui
ira dans le bon sens il aura le soutien
on n'est pas enfermé dans les postures
partisanes voulezêt des journalistes
beaucoup plus que nous croyez-mi ah oui
oui Non Non mais donc il est vraiment
aussi il est en soutien des écoutez moi
j'étais ravi qu' m'apporte son soutien
aux élections de certains parce qu' y a
très peu de du C tien d'Alain Jupé
Natalie CUS comorisé Mael de Calan un de
ses proches et vous moi j'ai beaucoup de
respect d'affection pour Alain Jupé j'ai
été très heureux de travailler avec lui
dans le cadre de cette primaire c'est un
grand monsieur c'est un excellent mer de
mais c'est un homme d'État et encore une
fois je sais que je j'ai toujours la
capacité d'appeler àin Jupé quand j'ai
pas les idéesire sur quelque chose pour
lui demander son regard et et je me
réjouis de son soutien à boulon billon
courourors pour continuer sur sur ce
sujet Édouard Philippe le Premier
ministre qui est un de vos amis hein
vous nous l'avez dit va aller soutenir
Yv g le candidat udi qui n'est donc pas
estampi à la République en marche jeud
dis est-ce que vous souhaitez également
qu'il vienne vous soutenir euh d'abord
je sais que j'ai le soutien d'Édouard
Philippe qui est un un ami personnel et
qui me souhaite le meilleur pour les
élections législatives mais il y a
beaucoup de travail il invité à boulong
billancour il est invité permanent à
boulong billancour autant qu'il le
souhaiteen mais écoute je sais pas j'ai
pas encore quel est ça j'avais jean-l
borlau qui est venu ce matin mais et
françois Barouin on parle de la venue de
franç bar fr dit qu' viendrait dimanche
pour me soutenir à boulill en cours mais
vous savez encore une fois tout ça c'est
très intéressant les électeurs ils sont
grands ils comprennent beaucoup mieux ce
que tout le monde croit la situation ce
qu'il faut c'est leur dire les choses et
pas leur mentir et faire l'inverse après
ce qu'on avait dit pendant la campagne
moi je dis les choses clairement en
votant pour moi ils savent pour qui
votent allez le message est bien passé
ben on va regarder un tableau avec tous
les candidats que vous affrontez quand
même dans la 9e circonscription des
hautes scènes merci beaucoup Orian merci
Thierry solaire on vous retrouvera on
verra à l'Assemblée nationale ou
ailleurs enfin manifestement prêt à
soutenir de manière constructive
l'action du nouvel exécutif on vous a
compris merci bonsoir à tous
[Musique]
bons